este es el volcán krakatoa que acaba de
estallar hace unos 20 minutos
aproximadamente otra vez la última vez
que estalló fue en el año
1873 y en torno al 70% del archipiélago
quedó destruido
y es posible que ahora mismo dentro de
poco vayan a morir muchas personas
no en serio no no hace falta que lo
busquéis es mentira
lo que quería con esto para empezar y
romper el hielo un poco no es que os
deis cuenta de lo fácil que es en pleno
siglo veintiuno desinformar lo fácil que
es en pleno siglo 21 mentir y hacer
pasar por algo real algo que no es real
con todas las redes sociales con todos
los medios que tenemos a nuestro abasto
lo fácil que es montar también en pleno
siglo 21 un medio de comunicación para
lo bueno y para lo malo obviamente no
entonces a mí esto me ha llevado en
estos últimos tiempos a reflexionar
mucho y me ha llevado a pensar al
respecto de esto no porque de la misma
manera que los medios de comunicación se
pueden utilizar para hacer el bien se
pueden utilizar para construir una
sociedad más justa una sociedad más
democrática para promover ciertos
valores y para contar al final historias
que se han quedado sin contar para
relatar hechos para hacer entrevistas a
personas que crees que merecen ser la
pena de entrevistadas y que no lo son y
también para promocionar el talento como
se está haciendo hoy aquí
entonces hoy voy a centrar en esta
charla en hablar de todas aquellas cosas
positivas que nos pueden traer los
medios de comunicación y en cómo a
partir de mi experiencia he intentado
mejorar la comunicación he intentado
mejorar los medios de comunicación he
intentado luchar contra la pandemia de
la desinformación y de la soledad que se
vive en pleno siglo 21
bueno televisión española estrena de
españoles en el mundo con crudos
testimonios de periodistas que aún
sobreviven a la prensa escrita pero más
allá de bromas esta es una realidad que
la verdad es que nos acompaña cada día
no
yo la verdad es que cuando vi que esta
charla tenía como temática crisis me
paré a pensar y dije a ver yo de otra
cosa puede que no entienda pero creo que
de eso de las crisis la verdad es que lo
llevo bastante bien me metí a
periodistas de letras
me puse a estudiar en esta época tan
convulsa dos crisis económicas seguidas
una pandemia y alguien da más por favor
boomers abstenemos un poco en este
aspecto
entonces la verdad es que me paré a
reflexionar me paré a pensar un poco
sobre el periodismo y os voy a contar mi
historia a partir de toda esta cuestión
hoy a partir de la situación que vivimos
yo siempre querido ser periodista no yo
desde chiquitito estaba con la consola
en casa de mis abuelos mis abuelos me
miraban y yo me ponía a jugar y me ponía
a radiar los partidos le quitaba el
volumen y los radio a gallo y ahí me di
cuenta de que de que me gustaba mucho el
periodismo y de que quería ser
periodista en el futuro luego un poquito
más adelante ya también me di cuenta de
que me gustaba escribir ya con 13 14
años monté mi primer blog me puse a
hacer mis primeras entrevistas a conocer
a gente y bueno me di cuenta de que eso
era algo muy interesante sobre algo que
me nacía y porque claro a veces lo
pienso y digo oye te hubiera salido
quizás más rentable no meterte a
publicista guionista de black mirror a
psicólogo no ahora con la pandemia
también de crisis mental de salud mental
que estamos viviendo entonces yo pensé
igual es que te compensa más meterte a
todas estas cosas pero no la verdad es
que por suerte o por desgracia yo elegí
ser periodista y esta es mi historia ya
con 18 años decidí decidirme a la
universidad decidí irme a madrid porque
al final creo que para cumplir nuestros
sueños a veces hay que dejar cosas atrás
hay que dejar personas atrás y bueno yo
decidí irme a madrid y comencé allí una
nueva etapa
allí por fin conocí a gente con los
mismos intereses a gente con los mismos
gustos que yo a gente que pensaba cosas
parecidas y cosas diferentes pero que
tenía metas y tenía sueños y tenía una
visión del mundo que compartía conmigo y
ahí te ves en los primeros días no tan
ilusionado tanto tan bonito con tus
compañeros planeando cómo va a ser un
poco el futuro y bueno ahí la verdad es
que nada más llegar a clase nos dimos un
golpe bastante duro de realidad cuando
nos dimos cuenta de que muchos
profesores daban nos daban como que todo
estaba ya por perdido como que no
podíamos aspirar a cambiar la realidad
sino simplemente a llegar a un medio de
comunicación hacer lo que pudiéramos y
ya está no pero bueno desde el principio
se formaron dos grupos de personas y
esto te das de esto te das cuenta muy
rápidamente en las cervezas que te haces
después de clase cuando quedas con los
demás te pones a hablar te pones a
compartir historias y ahí me di cuenta
de que teníamos que hacer algo más
aparte de ir a la universidad para
aprender a ser periodistas como pasan
muchas otras profesiones
y entonces me di cuenta de que otros de
mis compañeros también se habían dado
cuenta y esto la verdad es que a mí me
pareció súper bonito y bueno ya desde el
principio se veía a algunas personas que
por lo que fuera no tenían el tiempo no
tenían tenían que trabajar tenían que
aceptar empleos precarios y no podían
ponerse a emprender sus propios
proyectos dentro del mundo del
periodismo había otros que simplemente
no tenían ganas porque preferían hacer
otras cosas cosa que es también muy
lícito y bueno ya hubo algunos no que
desde el principio como que teníamos
mucho interés en el tema estábamos
buscando medios pero claro no es lo
mismo llegar con una lista de contactos
bajo el brazo no no es lo mismo llegar y
decir bueno ahora voy a llamar a estos
contactos que me han dado y voy a tener
un 3 mi primer trabajo como periodista y
voy a empezar entonces a veces hay que
ir un poco más allá y claro yo llegué
allí sin conocer prácticamente a nadie y
un día estaba haciendo scrolling en
twitter yo todas las mañanas me
levantaba ahí a buscar medios de
comunicación con toda la ilusión
y bueno me queda un poco sorprendido
cuando vi un medio que se llamaba la
revista mira al espejo en castellano
porque había dos frases que me habían
llamado muchísimo la atención la primera
de ellas era periodismo sense empresa
periodismo sin prisa y la segunda era
nueva cultura contra la tristeza y la
precariedad nueva cultura contra la
tristeza y la precariedad y claro cuando
yo vi aquello dije yo quiero escribirá y
enseguida contacte con el director del
medio hicimos el contacto lo llamé y
nada sale mal envía un mensaje directo
pero no lo conocía no lo no lo podía
llamar y entonces allí que me lancé me
dejé la vergüenza atrás y le hablé y le
dije mira yo quiero escribir aquí qué
puedo hacer entonces me dijo bueno pues
ya que tienes 18 años que acabas de
empezar ponte a escribir en blogs voy
haciendo y después ya veremos qué pasa y
bueno allí que me lanzaba a esta a esta
nueva a esta nueva aventura y bueno con
todo total
estando allí nos miramos en esto
empezamos a escribir empezó a ir todo
muy bien y lo demás lo voy a contar
ahora pero primero quiero hacer un breve
alegato no porque muchas veces se dice
de los jóvenes que
se nos critica mucho no se dice que no
tenemos ganas de trabajar se dice que no
tenemos ganas de emprender nuestros
propios proyectos se dice que nuestra
generación somos unos vagos yo quiero
romper una lanza en defensa de nuestra
generación porque muchas veces se cuenta
la cara pero no se cuenta la cara ve la
cara de la crisis la cara de los empleos
precarios la cara de que no podemos
trabajar de lo nuestro la cara de tener
que aceptar cualquier trabajo de [ __ ]
o tener que resignarnos y bueno esto la
verdad es que muchas veces no se cuenta
no yo siempre pongo un ejemplo que es el
ejemplo de los telediarios que alguien
me expliqué si los jóvenes después de
ver un telediario en el que solo hay
muertes tristeza desolación precariedad
y catástrofes tenemos después ganas de
ponernos a emprender y tenemos ganas de
ponernos con nuestros propios proyectos
pero yo sinceramente creo que sí y yo
creo que tenemos que ser nosotros los
que cambiamos esto porque nadie nos lo
va a regalar y tenemos que ser nosotros
los que nos pongamos encima de la mesa y
nos pongamos a construir nuestros
propios proyectos así que en favor de
eso quiero romper una lanza
y bueno continuando un poquito con mi
historia
ya cuando la revista iba muy bien y tal
yo continuaba mis blogs mis primeros
haters mis primeras entrevistas es un
momento muy bonito la verdad la vida de
un periodista y entonces de repente me
di que me llamaba el director de la
revista se había creado hace poco una
delegación en madrid entonces el
director me dice oye que jordi quieres
crear la delegación tú en valencia de
cero o sea yo te dejo aquí y tú vas vía
libre te cedo mi marca y esto es un
proyecto tuyo y bueno la verdad es que
al principio me quedé un poco me queda
un poco entraron un poco de escalofríos
y me dio miedo
pero claro yo pensé creo que esto es una
de las oportunidades que está dando la
vida jordi y creo que la tienes que
[ __ ] tienes que ir a por ella tienes
que tirar hacia adelante y lo que tenga
que ser ya será no y bueno la verdad es
que yo no tenía ni puñetera idea con
perdón de cómo se dirigía a un medio de
cómo se hacían las cosas y claro al
final para los que no lo sepa eso es un
proceso un poco complicado porque
primero tienes que crear una plantilla
de redactores y redactores tienes que y
empezar a construir un poco todo ese
medio tienes que empezar a buscarte más
tienes que definir una línea editorial
tienes que organizar cómo vas a
gestionar el plan en redes sociales
tienes también que ir poco a poco
entrevistando gente tienes que hacerte
un hombre tienes que salir los medios de
comunicación para que es un poco
paradójico pero que los medios salgan en
los medios ayuda también a visibilizar
esos medios y bueno la verdad es que es
es un poco con lo que con lo que me
quedé y me lancé y para adelante
continuamos y todo siguió y fue muy bien
la verdad y estoy muy contento en ese
sentido hay muchos días en los que me
pongo triste y en los que veo que pues
que la situación está mal no que hay
mucha precariedad que vivimos un momento
muy complicado y claro me para pensar y
digo oye jordi de verdad has hecho bien
en meterte donde te has metido de verdad
vale la pena esta lucha de verdad vale
la pena estar constantemente ahí un poco
entre la espada y la pared
y en todos esos días me acuerdo que
cuando viaje a argentina estuve allí
estudiando tuve la suerte de descubrir a
mario benedetti que es uruguayo pero
bueno lo conocí allí y él decía una
frase que es muy bonita que decía que
quiere defender la alegría como una
trinchera defenderla del escándalo y la
rutina de la miseria de los miserables
de las ausencias transitorias y las
definitivas y bueno también hay otra
frase que me inspira mucho que me la
dijeron mis abuelos que no eran tan
duchos en la materia como benedetti pero
que de la vida sabía mucho y siempre me
decían aquello de que trabajase y de que
fue esa buena persona que tratase bien
al resto de la gente y que me iría bien
no sé cómo quedaré no pero bueno yo de
momento lo sigo intentando y me ayuda
mucho cuando cuando la situación se pone
difícil cuando la situación se pone
tensa me ayuda me ayuda bastante creer a
mis abuelos porque al final me di cuenta
también de que la vida y sobre todo para
nosotros para los jóvenes
era levantarse y luchar volver a caerse
volver a levantarse volver a luchar y
volver a caerse y al final hasta que se
acabe la vida creo que no nos queda otra
que tenemos que ser jóvenes el mayor
tiempo posible así que creo que este
consejo nos lo tenemos que aplicar
y ahora al respecto de esto os quiero
contar algo que creo que os gustará y es
que la historia de nuestra generación es
la historia de blabla car es la historia
de muchos viajes es la historia de
muchas relaciones efímeras esa historia
de relaciones líquidas es la historia de
cosas que se acaban es la historia de un
precipicio en el que parece que estamos
siempre y nunca acabamos de caer y nunca
acabamos de ver la luz y aunque haya
muchos momentos oscuros creo que
nosotros somos la generación bla bla car
y somos la generación bla bla car porque
entre otras cosas hay muchas otras
aplicaciones que también nos definen
pero esta es mi historia
un día conocí a mi amigo adrián en un
bla bla car por aquel entonces a la
primera vez que yo me iba a madrid esas
son relaciones que te marcan mucho
porque aunque después no vuelvas a ver a
esas personas al final te quedas un poco
con eso no te quedas con esas primeras
amistades que te marcan yo conocía a
diría la primera vez que me fui a madrid
en blabla card 18 años había vivido en
un pueblo de 5 mil años de 5000
habitantes toda mi vida y bueno eso que
quiere a madrid no y al final me despedí
de este de este chico que me había caído
también nunca nos dimos los teléfonos y
yo creía que la historia no nos iba a
volver a juntar hasta que pasaron dos
años y bueno dos años después pasó una
cosa que es que nos volvimos a encontrar
en el mismo bla bla car y entonces si mi
amigo adhería me agregó como jordi mira
y bla bla y ahí nació una amistad que no
fue una amistad únicamente de dos
personas que comparten muchos intereses
y muchos y muchos gustos
al día siguiente estábamos en mi casa y
me pidió que quería colaborar con
nosotros que las dos semanas estábamos
en el palau de la vicepresidencia de la
generalitat entrevista a mónica oltra y
el estado allí con su cámara y después
estaba editando me ese vídeo y creo que
esta es la historia de nuestra
generación de una generación que a pesar
de todos los golpes y que a pesar de
todas las dificultades y de que a pesar
de todos los problemas que nos vienen
encima se levanta y se levantará una y
mil veces y eso también es lo que quiero
reivindicar hoy aquí y puede que haya
mucha gente que os diga que es mucho
mejor ir solos en el mundo y que es
mucho mejor
destruir al de al lado si se puede y que
es mucho mejor ponerle la zancadilla y
que es mucho mejor enfadarse y que es
mucho mejor preocuparnos sólo de
nosotros pero como me dijeron una vez la
patria es el otro y es cuidar a la otra
persona no cuidar al que piensa
diferente cuidar al que está en el otro
lugar y creo que en los equipos humanos
que los medios de comunicación para
dignificar de nuevo el periodismo y para
dignificar la vida que al final es lo
que creo que tenemos que hacer es
fundamental
entendamos que en equipo avanzaremos
mucho más y que al final en cualquier
disciplina yo tengo mis sueños en el
periodismo pero vosotros tendréis
vuestros sueños en el mundo de la
ciencia tendréis vuestros sueños en el
mundo de la gastronomía
tendréis vuestros sueños de montar os un
negocio y de tener una vida con vuestro
negocio de poner vuestro proyecto en
marcha no cada uno al final creo que
tendremos nuestros propios sueños pero
al final se trata de eso se trata de
construir en común se trata de construir
unidos y se trata en un mundo en el que
intentan que gobierne los algoritmos
volvamos otra vez a gobernar las
personas
así que muchísimas gracias y me quiero
despedir hoy aquí con una frase que
con varias frases pero sobre todo con
una frase que decía
que decía un filósofo alemán que era
bastante bastante listo no a mí me gusta
mucho y siempre decía que
a la hora de construir el futuro tenemos
que construir un futuro en libertad en
el que nos quedemos todos los jóvenes
nos quedemos
con todas las cosas que teníamos por
decir dichas y con todas las cosas que
teníamos por hacer hechas así que desde
aquí un saludo a mis abuelos
por cierto
acompañamos rodeados siempre de toda la
gente que crea en vuestros sueños y
sacarlos hacia adelante muchas gracias
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]